a government watchdog is expressing
concern over the dangerous misuse of
laundry detergent in this latest social
media fad teenagers are putting
detergent pods in their mouths and
posting the videos online Anna Werner is
here with why this is so risky and a
good morning all right and it might seem
obvious I mean what's in these things
ingredients like ethanol hydrogen
peroxide and polymers it's a highly
toxic and poisonous mix of detergent
meant to wipe out dirt and grime
consumer groups have been alarmed by
toddlers mistakenly ingesting them but
now teens are popping them in their
mouths on purpose and recording the
results many of the social media videos
are recorded and posted by minors
they're putting poisonous laundry pods
in their mouths for clean and internet
faith to one they call it the tide pod
challenge 19 year old Mark bogan did it
on a dare he told us he knew better but
did it anyway
a lot of people were just saying how
stupid I was or how well why would I be
willing to do that you don't want you to
be putting anything like that in their
mouths you know now authorities say this
is what started out as a joke on the
Internet and now it's just gone too far
Anne Marie Buerkle is acting chairman of
the Consumer Product Safety Commission
she says ingesting any of the liquid
carries a deadly risk the pods are
bright and colorful and to children they
can look like candy at least 10 deaths
have been linked to ingesting the pods
two were toddlers eight were seniors
with dementia Procter & Gamble the maker
of Tide products told CBS News they
should not be played with even if meant
as a joke
safety is no laughing matter same
cleaning power with a child resistant
tub more than 62 thousand children under
the age of 6 were exposed to laundry and
dishwasher detergents between 2013 and
2014 the next year Consumer Reports said
it would no longer recommend detergent
packets citing the unique risks while
urging the
option of tougher safety measures Merkel
says her group has worked with
manufacturers to make the packets less
attractive to children making that
laundry packet opaque less attractive
less colorful reducing the toxicity and
the strength of laundry detergent
the CPSC also found that elderly adults
with dementia were confused by the
product and some of them obviously
ingested it the danger to little kids of
these things is so high that researchers
in a study recommended that parents not
buy them at all if they have kids under
the age of say six years old that the
risk is too high and they're too
dangerous they said by regular laundry
detergent
I see where they're attractive to little
guys I get that but teenagers just for a
joke on the Internet makes no sense
right and these are the people who are
playing in traffic or sticking keys in
the light socket I mean yes yeah
listening to see if they do change the
packaging thank you Anna
thank you very much